y annoncer ce quiz auto stop pour jouer
un petit jeu d'horreur safilo tourner
sur burger leur punk eur16 excusez moi
c'est la maladie voilà je suis
actuellement atteints d'une
rhinopharyngite maladie que je possède
chaque année c'est très agréable c'est
partie introduction toulon et peter
grimes tu t'es retrouvé dans une tempête
et ut abrité dans un bunker
moi personnellement je m'abrite dans une
cabine téléphonique ans arrive d'écart
entre et la porte s'est fermée derrière
toi tu as une lampe torche avec toi un
peu de nourriture et d'eau est ton but
c'est de trouver la sortie de ce
de bunker je crois qu'on vient de
rentrer dans le bunker alors à bombay
dit le papier ce rêve pas allumer la
lampe torche donc là pas de se faire
aider à nous on élague aux timides somme
j'ai aucune idée de ce que ça veut dire
du coup y'a quoi y'a plein de pièces
comme ceux ci des barils et rhino
pharyngite ici donc c'est eux pour
ouvrir oui et ensuite on ok ok donc ça
sert de dortoir
at je suis pas fatigué pour dormir mais
on pourra dormir plus tard à les
premiers indices il se passe quoi la
waho c'est horrible ça fait beaucoup
d'avoir cette option sur sa lampe torche
en plus je ne connais pas fatigué alors
fait qu'on se bat dans ce petit bunker
on sait pas ce qu'a eue il ya des
douches et ou la salive est absolument
personne dans les douches
on va sortir vous en faites pas lui on
va y arriver bordel au moins on peut
contaminer personnes on est seul dans ce
tome bunker à une note
dans la soirée du 1er novembre journal
de george walker il y a un trou à clé
dans la porte mais bien sûr je n'ai pas
de clé et bah oui faut la trouver cette
petite clé mon enfant aïeux un de
bruit la deux du fdp là hop là une
petite lumière ça fait du bien ou pas
assez vraiment bien fait la notion du
noir vraiment excellent il donne à cette
petite cuisine note officier je suis je
suis supposé attendent une conversation
skype à 10 heures du soir je dois
trouver le moyen de partir d'ici
j'espère qu'il ya une sortie de secours
ou une fenêtre qui est assez large pour
que je passe un grand merci à la
personne qui a monté la torche et les
piles aa qu'est ce que c'est les plombs
sauf qu'on va en a qu un plomb pour six
pièces est parfait j'ai des piles à
l'infini ou pas en fait je ne sais pas
non plus hein qu'est les yeux c'est quoi
ce bordel assedic elle quoi le truc du
talent et votre toit directement plutôt
que jouer avec ma lampe torche fdp et a
peur de moi je suis courageux
touch courageux à moi à les fenêtres
sont vraiment assez large pour que je
puisse passer à merci bunker c'est très
aimable
une autopsie va d'un train de chercher
depuis une heure ou deux mais je perds
quelques tables de trouver la clé
j'avais une clé anglaise je pourrais
peut être retiré les boulons vis que
yade sera porte principale de bien sûr
je n'en ai pas je trouve un moyen de
m'enfuir dessinons mais vraiment et si
on allait dormir des peut-être fatima
temps qu'il a marché un petit peu
quelques mètres je suis très fatigué
j'ai vu des lits dans l'une des chambres
je vais faire une sieste et puisse
continuer à chercher la clé quand je me
réveillerai ben voilà juste là oui mais
quelle source de tension extrême
allez on se réveille on se couche pardon
gbp / f alors là c'est une thématique
qui a demandé un gros budget un peu les
effets spéciaux maman il ya des bruits
des bruits de pas il ya des bruits de
claix a eu un bruit de porte etc la fin
les newell avoir rien de plus banal
finalement il a déposé deux notes il a
pris soin de nous le 2 novembre et les
bruitages gluck commence nokia des
cosmologistes notes et les bruits de pas
bordel quand je me suis réveillé j'ai
entendu des bruits venir dedans dehors
de ma chambre
j'espère que c'est quelqu'un qui a
ouvert la porte principale et qui est
entré dans le bunker guarbecque
teichmann
je me suis mis sous ma couette je refais
personnes il ya des bruits
il ya des bruitages me chie dessus dès
que je suis sorti de ma chambre
les bruits sont emballés la porte
principale est toujours fermée il ya
personne aux alentours est évasive j'ai
fait du krav maga direct ah sur
faire mais chut day krav maga house is
not la baja voyait à lui few aux eaux
aya débrouillard il ya des bruits de
guerre ça donne des frictions telles
ambiances et les incroyables sans
déconner je commence à transpirer un
petit feu le 2 novembre
je viens de réaliser qu'il ya des
caisses qui sont pas au même endroit qui
hier qu'elle phoque comme si quelqu'un
avait cherché quelque chose est ce que
quelqu'un est entré un bunker pendant
que je dormais pour et il est encore ici
je me suis armé d'un tuyaux en acier et
leur ai dit de se montrer et
montrez-vous direct ça a vraiment marché
à cette porte là est bloqué c'est très
bien allez on va dire cette note en ce
qu'on fait que de lire finalement
atelier lecture aujourd'hui
bien sûr je n'ai pas de réponse du coup
j'ai continué à chercher dans le bunker
n'y a pas un endroit où une personne
pourrait se cacher il est trouvé
personne
est ce que c'est possible qu'ils aient
quitté le bunker juste après je me suis
levé à temps en fait c'est un sherlock
bunker la manga en fait une sorte de
quête la fin vie dans le bunker du cnpac
ces masses je déteste au krav maga et
c'est horrible ce genre de chose en plus
juste avant jeudi que la porte est
bloqué juste avant vous n'aurez pas ma
folie ni ma liberté de penser depuis je
n'ai pas réussi à trouver quelqu'un j'ai
décidé d'attendre à côté de la porte
principale à attendre leur retour
armé de ma clé à molette je suis
maintenant assis sur le sol j'ai attendu
trois heures près de l'entrée rien n'est
arrivé tout ce que je pouvais en temps
des tessons de la pluie je vais
maintenant me lever et me remettre à
chercher dans le bunker j'ai peut-être
raté quelque chose
ce quiz et narrateur ou pas alors qu'est
ce qu'il ya là dedans rien rien holnon
il n'ya pas de clé j'espère qu'il n'y a
rien d'autre à faire que d'attendre leur
retour
j'espère qu'ils ne sont pas des
criminels et s'il avait caché quelque
chose ici et que maintenant qu'ils sont
venus le chercher
ils ne reviendront jamais tant de
possibilités tant de 2,2 suspense dans
ce schéma là vraiment je suis à fond
dans ce but je trouve l'ambiance du jeu
a très peu dans le mois un petit bruit
au dos du fait que l'auteur fois kaka
culotte maman culotte un peu fou de voir
sa mère dans sa culotte a qui pleurent
qui pleure c'est la douche stupeur
petite torche non mais c'est pas grave
on est un petit peu d'ajax et c'est fini
a pu achever en attention sera attaqué
regardez j'ai fait une barricade là ok
je suis de nouveau ainsi devant l'entrée
principale
j'ai encore inspecté la porte mais il ya
aucun moyen que je loupe sans la clé je
fais le point sur les options qui
s'offrent à moi dans ma tête
malheureusement il y en a pas beaucoup
en fait y en a que deux soit quelqu'un
ou l'apport depuis l'extérieur soit je
mourrai ici le 3 novembre mais non dis
pas ça a sûrement raison mais dis pas ça
on peut dormir de nouveau nom n'est pas
assez fatigué on n'est pas fatigué
savoir en colonie dans le bunker ça j'ai
passé trente minutes à attendre devant
la porte principale avec ma barre de fer
il ne me reste que très peu d'eau et de
nourriture et aucun des robinets de
marche est-ce que je viens juste
d'entendre quelqu'un je suis choqué non
non non non pas du tout bas mais
personne ne sait où est la feuille
hausse à me tordre si tu restes dans
l'ombre pendant trop longtemps tu as
conscience que joue des tours c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de
m'arriver je vois des mouvements dans
l'ombre ouest acro chose qui joue des
tours vraiment si on m'en parle mais qui
veut tuer avec un couteau
j'ai besoin de dormir je laisserai la
porte de la chambre ouverte juste au cas
où ils reviennent c'est bien voilà comme
ça ils vont pouvoir des rangées de
manière très simple du coup il faut que
je retourne dormir puisque la ligue
était alors ça c'est horrible on voit
que c'est de la fumée haut le jeu
qui te fait peur pour des trucs nul quoi
tu as affaire il balance ducasse faut
que j'aille demain c'est mon imagination
qui me joue des tours et tout quoi on va
dormir
fuck you what ta femme et ses adjoints
tempête pièce que c'est quoi ce tableau
que le clou avec cet homme chien d'or
met en place voilà les faillites à
quelqu'un crier
une porte qui grince ça c'est un mec qui
traîne une hache un truc comme ça on est
d'accord alors allumé la lampe torche
on passe maintenant aux 3 devant mais
c'est toujours le journal de george
walker je n'ai pas du tout bien dormi
j'ai été réveillé par le bruit de
quelque chose qui était en train d'être
déplacé ça ressemblait au son d'une
étagère ou d'une pierre qui étaient
poussés sur du béton j'ai couru en
dehors du dortoir ou mais qu'il a
il a des couleurs titan mais dès que
j'étais sorti le bruit c'était en aller
pourquoi il ya un mur ici il n'y avait
pas mieux réussi hier c'était pas
possible mais c'est un vrai mur bien dur
où je suis qu'est ce qui se passe ici
quoi qu'ils pleurent mais qu'est ce qui
se passe ici la disposition de tout le
bunker a changé cette nuit la cuisine
qui est censé être en bas des marches et
maintenant à gauche et après l'entrée
est ce que c'est en train de devenir fou
oui mais tu deviens fou mon gars tu es
dans un bunker seul depuis deux jours un
moment voilà moi j'ai pas de ces trucs
là là je les trouve hyper un flip en
maintenant un que bayal disnat france
je fais du krav maga et je viens je
viens pour pour donner des leçons par
exemple il ya des bruits pendant un
moment où je pensais que c'était
peut-être juste un rêve je me suis
claqué le visage plusieurs fois mais ça
ne m'a pas aidé et je suis toujours là
c'est vraiment un train d'arriver quel
est cet endroit n'a pas principal est
toujours au même endroit mais bien sûr
elle est toujours fermé c'est comme si
les couloirs étaient encore plus étroits
et le plafond encore plus bas ça valait
claustrophobe et tout d'un coup l'air
sur le renfermé est ce que le système de
ventilation s'est arrêté est ce possible
de suffoquer ici à là le regard de
courage ont gardé ta gueule tu y as 20
mai et bae avait un visage un visa y
avait un visa y avait un visa y avait un
visage on a fait tout et notamment la
villa le bunker est devenu tout petit un
peu un bon comme tu habites un taux qui
est le cas chez ses abonnés comme ça et
je rigole a touché une grosse vague rose
il est ici on vous le savez les habitats
et je parle de zineb daoudi à quel point
je suis stressé quoi je ne suis pas seul
et si je n'ai jamais été j'ai entendu
des bruits bizarres des chuchotements de
l'obscurité
je transpire beaucoup je devrais plus
boire mais il n'y a plus d'eau et là
dans la pierre quoi maintenant dans son
streamer au nom des accusés ne sais pas
le vieux pas qu'à bruxelles on truque
quand on est tous âges et transpire moi
aussi je suis foutu il a cette photo
avec marquet cot metals
mais je jure comme approchons de cette
photo j'ai vu apparaître un visage
qu'elle était la personne dans la photo
d'où viennent ces voies je suis fatigué
abbas et leurs deux oreilles
donc j'ai plus de lampes torches dos aux
mais je vais mourir
oh non je dois tout refaire non non non
non si bas on est de retour dans la
salle donc il faut lire la note voilà
blablabla on l'a déjà vu et ensuite
c'est là que voilà on voit le visage
apparaît tellement l'ait pas vu j'avais
fait ça avant de dire ça voilà c'est ce
passionnant en fait il faut et à la
lampe torche qu'on lit les notes sinon
la batterie suis énormément et on perd
le jeu et on doit tout recommencer
en attendant on va longuement se pieuter
alors il faut retrouver la bête drôme
chut c'est ma pratique tout ça doit être
fermée depuis le début ils nous ont
habitués à l'air que dénote donc
forcément quoi vainqueur par et on est
où les moyens en quoi alors on dort
qu'est-ce qui se passe owens et matis
carrément attendant juste à la batterie
et au talent de temps il reste plus que
le lit est né et des murs bondirait
paranormal activity vu en première
personne mon dieu oh la la
ou alors c'est les vagues et secourir ou
est-ce qu'on n'a pas assez là pas fini
oui
ah ah je vais péter le fémur d'ouvrir la
porte excusez moi je veux plus voir la
femme en pyjama au crâne rasé ressort de
questions n'a pas en principe assurée et
à l'est elles étaient toutes en est
maintenant elle est plus là a tancé
mais oui c'est vrai ça il était là-bas
il n'y a aucun moyen de s'en aller je
vais mourir dans ce trou et moi
j'aimerais finir ce jeu donc j'aimerais
que tu meurs en faites pas je sais c'est
dégueulasse de dire ça je me balade aux
alentours sans but
ces photos moche il y en a plus
maintenant est-ce qu'elle j'essaye de me
dire quelque chose je ne comprends pas
allait abréger noah je sens du plâtre
sur ma langue
cela fait aussi longtemps que des passes
à bourges s'approche ça dégage bordel et
des craintes partout il ya des craintes
partout j'avais comme faut une clé non
demain avec la vente de mariage et la
clé mais j'ai pu la porte comme on fait
la clé où le cas d'un coffre
voilà c'est ça ok hop voilà j'ai les
eaux non au nom me dis pas que tu vois
que j'ai fait un truc qui fait que je
vais pas jusqu'à la fin du jeu non non
je m'endors
ça va et toi nickel très beau tom et
basso qui sert à rien salle du même coup
la laine comme ce la fin de la vidéo
eva l'agencé afin de ce jeu hyper
scénaristique vraiment et plein de notes
j'ai une vraie histoire et tourne à plus
de faire ce genre de truc ma voix unique
et mais franchement ça m'a plu et
j'espère que vous aussi si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo
exactement je retourne met en position
foetale dans mon lit pour faire une
belle petite sieste de rétablissement
j'espère que ça vous a plu
merci d'avoir regardé on se retrouvait
dans une prochaine vidéo et pas dans un
bourg prochain walker sa soeur de
questions tu as tout le monde puisse
oh